what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today
from our buddy paul over at heavy
spoilers
loki episode 5 theories and a whole
bunch
time keepers kang miss minutes loki
variance robota
obs had more more than that but this job
yeah john that joke's not old at all
it's not it's my favorite show
it's your favorite joke yeah it jokes
that no no one's bored of that joke yet
especially not me especially not
especially i'm not bored
of that joke
yes and i will continue to make it
well it's funny so keep making obviously
mephisto
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host polius and paulias
and after the ending of loki episode 4 i
think we have a lot to talk about
in this video heads will roll as we go
through what's happening with the time
keepers
let's just have eyes and what's with all
the lucky variants in the post-credits
scene almost yeah spoilers ahead so if
you don't anything ruin it then i
recommend you say bye bye frost and exit
the video as fast as possible
smash the thumbs up button if you enjoy
the breakdown and make sure you
subscribe as we're in the end game of
the series now
and you definitely don't want to miss
our breakdowns without the way thank you
for clicking the video
now let's get into our loki episode five
theories
okay so episode four ends with loki and
sylvie coming face to face with the
squidward trio
aka the timekeepers after throwing her
sword she beheaded the main one
and this exposed that they were actually
androids life model decoys or rather
lmd's
are some little pinked up in the marvel
universe at several points
and typically they're used for a reveal
just like this
they often indicate that someone has
either duplicated themselves in order to
appear a certain way
or that someone else is behind it all i
think i'll get them
to show you get the picture now when
they're broken apart
the robots look quite a lot like doom
bots and though he could be behind it
i actually think that it's unlikely he
would be in the tva instead i think
there are some far more likely
candidates that are pulling the strings
and the first potential is he who
remains in order to discuss him we have
to talk about how the universe works
and like all things it too comes to an
end
now when the universe dies it creates
something known as a heat death
that starts off the next universal cycle
and in the comics we discover that he
who remains was a tva member from the
previous one
he created the timekeepers and gave them
information so that on the next goal
they wouldn't make the same mistakes
and if we are keeping in with the comics
then he could be behind it all
now i think it's pretty unlikely that
it's him as he's always been
more of a force for good and the tva
themselves are quite sinister
thus it could actually be kang the
conqueror who has also been involved
with the organization
right after the release of that game
many people thought that kang would be
next
as when characters tend to mess with
time it tends to mess back
and he follows not long after jonathan
mages has been cast as the villain
and we do know that he's set to show up
in ant-man quantomania i find it so
funny how we king the conqueror i know
there are some people who are like
we don't know it's going to be k no this
be another one division situation
with mephisto don't let it be another
one of those
uh for all the fans but it's a very
different situation because of the fact
that king the conqueror as pointed out
by paul is going to be showing up in
ant-man quantum mania
at the very least he will be showing up
so it's not that far down the line and
you know how
connective tissue based all this mcu
stuff is so it's kind of funny because
he is kind of like the new mephisto
but one that more people actually
believe
they're only gonna contain this highly
significant villain to just one ant-man
movie and that's it
oh yeah however it would be pretty cool
to see him pop about the end of the show
in a sort of thanos at the end of the
avengers moment so we could get a tease
for what's coming down the line i think
it would be a cameo
from kronanopolis which was possibly
spotted in a bubble in the quantum realm
during ant-man in the wasp potentially
this is where the tva is located
and though it is typically placed in the
null time zone i think it would be a
very cool reveal that brings everything
together
now if kang is behind it all then it is
possible that he traveled through
every timeline and that he found the one
in which he could rule for eternity we
saw something similar in infinity war
when we learned there were over 14
million different scenarios for the
thanos battle
but only one in which the avengers won
potentially can could be in the one
where he is the ruler of all time
and in order to stop anyone from taking
his throne he's been pruning branches
throughout the multiverse
kang may have taken those who create
nexus events and wipe their memories
before putting them into his ranks so
that he could continue his quest to
exterminate everything in the multiverse
all that would be left was a dimension
in which he was unchallenged
and potentially the nexus event that
sylvie would have created
may have been her overthrowing him
obviously that's a completely wild
theory
but let me know below if you disagree i
mean i do feel like it would be
really neat if the tva is located in
chronopolis especially
if indeed this whole thing with ravona
being set up to be tied to king to
conquer and it really is king who's the
one controlling it they specifically
said
kang is going to be primarily featured
in ant-man quantum mania
it would just make more sense to have
that complete tie in there
where you know the quantum realm and all
that is mainly
explored in the ant-man movies to have
the tva in chronopolis within the
chronopolis being in the quantum realm
as t's and ant-man it would just tie it
all together in a much neater bow in my
personal opinion i i would love that
that would be a very neat reveal
oh yeah and it seems like then it would
be that loki is setting up way
more than just you know doctor strange
two and spider-man no way
maybe it connects to all of the upcoming
films and sets of things
little by little for all of them
definitely there is another person that
i think could be behind it all
and they've already been in the show
what if yeah just
sit down for a second what if this
entire thing
is actually miss minutes
[Music]
we know that there's an elevator button
and it is possible that she's the big
bad the timekeepers are robots
clocks are of course mechanical and the
city that the tva is based at
also looks like the inner workings of a
clock she's popped up in the series
so it wouldn't come completely out of
the blue and when she was talking to
loki
it seemed like she was recording but
also live at the same time
so lots of weird things going on with
the character and with tara strong
voicing her
i think it would be a cool little twist
to have it revealed that she said miss
minutes it's not the last we've seen of
him
loki doing it and potentially the show
may be pulling from the graphic novel
agent of asgard
in that it was revealed there was an
older version of the character pulling
the strings
and we did theorize that richard e grant
would be playing this
though he got the casting right and he
is going to be an old version of loki
judging from the post-credits scene it
seems like we were way off in terms of
his role
however it is worth going over him and
in the graphic novel we learned that it
was
old loki all along he was the one
manipulating the younger version to
excel to greatness
and considering loki has been nothing
but a stepping stone in the mcu
i think that it would be a great reveal
oh man
i love that i really love that
considering that you have your main
characters a loki variant
sylvie another loki variant who was
teased as like the antagonist of the
show come to find out no she's not
really the main antagonist of the series
but if you found out that
it was really a different very that's
why it's all about loki
within the tva when you do your tba base
show it's all about loki oh that would
be actually
really neat well it would continue the
theme of literal self self-confrontation
and
growth through experiencing yourself
through different lenses and everything
like that
i would love that i would love it
yeah oh man i'll reveal the miss minutes
what i've heard kind of tossed around a
little bit i don't buy it for some
reason
while she is like the tour guide and
your little
paper clip helper friend clippy
in so many ways it would be amusing to
me
um might even feel a little bit more
even wizard of oz-esque
to that degree perhaps i don't know
there's just something about it that i'm
not
it's not really clicking i just can't
see it right now i can't i can't imagine
that i feel like it'd be kind of goofy
yeah i can't exactly see it and i feel
like it would be the sort of thing where
if it is miss minutes then there would
have to be a reveal that like she's not
just this little sentient clock
animation like she's got to be
some other substantial being that's what
i meant by another
like it would be a human there would be
like another reveal
beyond that reveal yeah yeah the most
mcu
weight would be king but i think the
most character
weight would be another loki yeah that
would be i'm rooting for that theory
yeah that would be cool that'd be great
now at the end of the episode we meet
several versions of loki and it does
seem like next episode the main variant
will be recruiting more of these in
order to go and take down the tva
this would explain why boat lucky pops
up in the show and also
why in the trailers there's a brief
glimpse at king loki however beyond that
there may be one hiding under our noses
and it is possible that ravana ren
slayer herself is a loki
the series has confirmed that race and
gender don't matter when it comes to
loki
because of this yeah red slayer could
even be one herself
and this would explain why she felt some
sympathy towards selfie when she was a
child
somewhat how mobius is in the loop
constantly working with loki
ren slayer made to be stuck in one
constantly hunting them
hell the tva on above bringing lucky's
into the loki's
and this entire show started off on the
idea that tom hiddleston's version would
be tracking down selfie
thus it does make sense that she herself
could be one
and because the tva are able to wipe
memories this would be completely
unbeknownst to her
now there's no precedent for this in the
comics but i have no idea why
she was so sympathetic towards sylvie
and why she allowed her to escape
in the elevator she also smirked when
sylvie asked what nexus event she
created
and though she pretended not to know she
clearly did
and i also know it was you who fought it
in the elevator yeah
get that smile off your face i mean i
kind of just took the whole thing with
her
letting her go is because she wasn't in
the position she's in now ravana she was
a minuteman
right yeah yeah and she was like a
younger agent and to me it just seemed
kind of like that trope of the
sympathetic for the child
situation i don't know it's kind of odd
that she would have sympathy and to grow
to this very cold character but maybe
the journey of letting her go is what
made her turn so cold and let her down
kind of this path to not have that
sympathy for variance where she had a
moment of weakness back then i i looked
at it more like that i didn't really
view it as a like oh there's a big loki
twist reveal here
yeah i didn't really read any sympathy
out of that moment so much as it was
just like ah
little kid loki you know got one over on
me and i wasn't able to catch her
yeah you know it just seemed more like a
you know true error
for ravona at least now maybe this
entire show is her simply attempting to
be the superior loki
and the nexus event that sylvie created
was just her existing
i do feel that we're gonna get a twist
that someone who we think is one
character is actually a loki themselves
and if this had to be anyone my money
would be on rentslayer
however she also simply be the same as a
comic book counterpart
and working for kang in the comics the
two had a relationship
and it would make a lot of sense if she
is indeed tied in with him
now lastly i want to talk about what's
happened to mobius
in the episode he was apparently killed
but loki showed at the end that the
sticks of death could be survived
as he arrived in a decimated new york
potentially the same thing happened with
mobius
and he may even have been taken to
somewhere else in the timeline
trailers for the show have had him
driving along in a jeep in what
looks like egypt and thus we do know
that he's probably coming back at some
point
unless this is all a trick which you
won't fool me mephisto
i know it's you now on top of this i
think that there may be other versions
of mobius that are running around
in ren slayer's office he noticed there
were several ring stains
which she said had been left by him and
even though he brushed it off
he clearly thought it wasn't me now he
also
so really bad this video now he also
looked at pen which he said had been
given to her by another agent
in episode four he looked longingly over
this and it is possible that it comes
from his real life
in the comics there were several
versions of mobius and shout out to zgen
media on twitter
we're pointing out that the figure we
see dotted about in posters
[Music]
it's so funny because in new rockstars
and they were breaking uh that photo
down
we're like it's probably just a a
reference poster to kind of like those
classic
it's supposed to look like big brother
kind of like those like 1940s
vibes like a rod sterling-esque type of
characters who we thought we really
think it was a character that would
actually come to fruition yeah when you
put the
photos side by side they actually do
look remarkably similar
yeah would you also compare to the comic
book uh iteration of mobius 2 it
lends that much more credence too yeah i
love that
oh that would be a great reveal i mean i
don't think they'd go back to that post
i don't think it would be like
does that feel like a poster yeah but i
would love it if that poster
serves as some kind of clue because it
did really hone in on that poster
and they hone in on a lot of details
around the tva
maybe we weren't supposed to be looking
at the quote but we were supposed to be
looking at the face
yeah yeah that would be a a great
magic trick i think i definitely think
that mobius is stuck in his own loop
though
and i hope at some point that he breaks
it and gets to ride that jet ski
just give this man a jet ski give this
man a jet ski
and the pruning itself may not actually
be wiping people out
and judging off what's going on in the
post-credits scene i think the most
likely scenario is that the characters
are being teleported to a garbage
timeline
also known as 2020. the post-credits
scene
very much feels like it's a dumping
ground and it's almost a sort of
scrapyard timeline in which variants
that are no longer needed are sent to
you
this would mean that mobius might be
there too and i'd love it if they just
had
one big happy reunion and he got right
off of his jet ski
now obviously i lived in the real world
so make sure you comment below and let
me know thanks for the video paul by the
way guys i just want to say um
sincerely paul is someone who i feel
like i've been talking with
daily for like the past few weeks and
he's just an incredibly incredibly
huge [ __ ] i can't stand the kid
never helps out with anything and and
you try to open up with the guy or you
know become a bit vulnerable and he just
dismisses you he's
just so self-absorbed and only talks
about himself
and never inquires at all or tries to
lend a helping hand but is constantly
asking for [ __ ]
the absolute worst guy
ever and uh no one should like him
on his videos especially not his videos
and no one should subscribe to his
channel and no one should turn on the
notification bill for them paul's
amazing after doing youtube for so long
it's it's honestly rare to come across
someone as um as incredible of a human
being as he is
uh there's very few who i could say that
about me
maybe john
not cosmic wonder definitely not cosmic
wonder or tyrone
definitely not that not tyrone uh but
paul
yeah he's one of them probably the only
one he's the only one hey guys what are
your theories of loki episode
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to happyspoilers and cosmic winner
tyrone if you haven't done so click that
bell hit that like button and let's do a
look there's anyone who's a loki variant
anyone it is so blatantly obvious
who a loki variant would be i've gotten
to know a pretty good handful of the
people like more than half of people who
we shout shouted at our patreon
page it's just so easy to pinpoint who
this individual would be
based off of his personality his kind of
cynical sense of humor
offbeat charm just the nature of his
like flirtatious personality
it's it's eric horseman all right i
didn't even tell john who i was gonna
say gotta be
definitely eric for a subversion joke no
it's it's eric horstmann yeah easily oh
dude if eric horseman met a variant of
himself do you imagine how steamy that
would get
yeah he'd flick he would be flicking
that bean all day
he would eric i don't need to say
anymore you are looking you're a lucky
bear all right there's nothing more to
say buddy
i love you you rock one day we will have
a beer together
in the meantime just know you're the
assigned period it's just like
who is it by default